لو كان للزلزال عنوان عريض على الجانب
السوري وتحديدا الاكثر تضررا منه فسيكون
اللجوء داخل اللجوء مهجرون سوريون في
سوريا اربعه ملايين شخص هم في امس الحاجه
للمساعدات اكثر من 70% منهم قبل الزلزال
لا يجدون قوت يومهم بحسب الامم المتحده
مصيرهم الان من البيوت المتصدعه او ما
يشبهها وما لا يحتمل كم الهزات الارتداديه
الى العراء لا ملاجئ تاويهم بخلاف حال
المتضررين من الزلزال في مناطق سيطره
النظام ويؤكد انه فتح قرابه 80 ملجا
لاستيعاب من تهدمت بيوتهم اذا معاناه
الاربعه ملايين نازح قبل الزلزال وخمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون بعده ويتقاسم مروها
منهجره الصراع الى ما خلف الحدود الجنوب
التركي الذي بات منكوبا الان هنا مليون
وسبعمائه
من اصل ثلاثه ملايين وسبعمائه الف سوريه
يعيشون في تركيا غازي عنتاب مركز الزلزال
الاول تحتضن 460 الف لاجئ هاتاي 430 الف
330 الفا كل من 200 الف لاجئ وبالمناسبه
عدد السوريون السوريين فيها اكبر من عدد
السكان المحليين او يساوي رسميا واحد من
كل شخصين في المقاطعات سوري لاجئ بحسب
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين فالى
من يلجا هؤلاء في بلد اللجوء بعضهم انضم
الى اربعين الف متضرر احتوتهم ملاجئ
وفنادق حكوميه وبعضهم وجد في العوده الى
الديار وان كانت بيوتهم مسحوقه ملاذا او
ربما لم يمتلكون الخيار عائلات في انطاكيا
توجهت الى ادلب علها تحصل على بعض
المساعدات من المنظمات المحليه اصطدموا
بالمعابر المغلقه في الايام الاولى ان
تفتح لهم باجازه يمكنهم الذهاب الى سوريا
لكن العوده غير ممكنه قبل ثلاثه اشهر على
الاقل
[موسيقى]
هون هون
يا رب يا رب
يلا قولي يا رب وصلت قريب عليك خمس دقايق
قولي يا رب
يا شباب
[موسيقى]
اعطونا حرام نغطيه
يوم الاثنين
حوالي
اتفقنا على هزه الارض عندي الولاد نايمين
بغرفه ثانيه فزيد
على الحيطان الحيطه يعمل عندي هيك بالبيت
يعني الاولاد من الهزه قوه الهزه
وضلنا قاعدين شو بدنا نساوي
عم نصلي على النبي وموحد الله
برا البيت
[موسيقى]
اول ما بلشت الهزه الارضيه